Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host Rawkode.
Before we get started, I just wanna take
ten seconds to thank my employer, Equinix Medal.
They allow me the time and energy and
resources
to spend my day working on these streams
and producing content so we can all learn
together.
Today, I am joined by a former colleague
of mine, Ian George. Hey, Ian. How are
you? Hey. I'm doing great. How about yourself?
Yeah. I'm doing alright. Thank you. So
you we work together at Infox Data. You
worked on InfoxDB.
You're also the organizer of the Orlando Go
user group.
That's right. We meet every Wednesday.
Every Wednesday. That keeps you busy as well
then.
And and previous conversations, you've mentioned to me
that you used to do competitive programming.
So let's just quickly summarize all of those
things then in the next few minutes. So
feel free to give a quick introduction, and
then we'll kinda tackle them one at a
time. Sure. So just like you said, my
name is Ian George. We sort together at
Inplux. Frankly,
unfortunately, today is kinda like my first day
not Inplux. I'm kind of like in between,
what you call it, adventures.
And but it was genuinely
probably the best place I've ever worked because
of people like you.
Anyway, it's it's a wonderful place to work,
and I'm kinda missing my team or the
team that I was part of already today.
But this freaks me up to do cool
stuff like this. Yes.
I run the Orlando Golang meetup, and I'm
sorry. Said we do it every Wednesday. We
actually were doing every Wednesday, but I kinda
tapered it off. Frankly,
I I find that I pretty pretty quickly
run out of, like, ideas and speakers.
But for me, it's mostly social now. Like,
I I don't get a chance to get
out, so I enjoy just, like, hanging around
like my people.
And, yes,
my first exposure to
kind of competitive programming was in high school.
I used to I was in a program
where we went to technical schools half of
the day.
And at technical school, I was at the
IT program,
and they had a
an organization called Phi Beta Lambda. And there's
basically I don't remember the I don't actually
remember,
like, how I fell into that, but within
that had
awards that they would give. And one and
one of them was for kind of, like,
the IT track and required
a bit of competitive programming where we you
know the the the first one I did
was local, then I made it to the
to the national level in Washington, and we
we
we competed there where we were given a
problem and had to code it up.
And I've
somehow the other one won one at the
national level at the time. And then in
college, as part of the ACM, we used
to do the regional programming competition.
We made it
we made it as far as, I think,
Southeast Regional
competition.
So so, yeah, that that was that that
was kinda like my introduction to competitive programming.
But more importantly, it kind of introduced me
to these sorts of problems that we're about
to tackle today. Right? Kind of I can
try problems that you have to sort
of complete
under time constraints. So it's like a little
bit of pressure.
And yeah. That that's it.
Nice. I mean,
during competitive programming, it's just
damn. And I I I can't even think
about doing that kind of those problems and
trying to worry about all the constraints and
and being timed and competing.
Too stressful for me. Yeah. But but, unfortunately,
it's gonna mean it's gonna work out quite
well for you. I mean, you're now well,
you worked on a database, which is not
necessarily the easiest software to be working on
for a start. Right? Like, that is that
is tricky stuff that involves
optimizations and a whole bunch of other things.
And then there's advent of code. So, I
mean, no pressure. But this must be this
must be easy for you. Right? That's you're
just gonna smash it at the park in
fifteen minutes, and that is done. Right. Right.
Right. So so yeah. That's the thing about
especially at end of COVID, the way I've
been tackling it is I wake up in
the morning, kinda check it,
and, you know, sort of in the
kind of like a lot of these things
we do kind of the we we kinda
do in our in the privacy of our
own home and
and without any, like, pressure.
And so this does so doing this in
front of an audience does kinda add add
quite a bit of pressure. But one of
the cool things one of the things I
like about it is that
what I find is that you tend to
kinda bring your own toolbox to these problems.
You kinda bring the things, you know, whatever
algorithms, like language, constructs, stuff like that that
you know to a particular problem.
And
and once you solve the problem, that's that's
neat and interesting, but I think where it
becomes fun is to compare what you've done
with other people and see how they tackle
the problem in a different way because
what you find is that like, I have
a good friend who solved the previous
was it previous wrong? Anyway, in particular, I
have friends that I hang out with on
on Git I mean, on Slack. And almost
every day, we kinda start with, like, hey.
Have you done the new admin or code?
And what's always fun is to find out,
like, what things he did differently
to solve it that that I didn't that
I didn't do. And in in a way,
I kind of, like, learned to kind of
expand
my my toolbox.
I I I do that too. I mean,
time I do an advent of of code
problem, the first thing I do when I
finished it is go to get help search
for advent of code, filter it by what
was updated recently. Absolutely.
Just look at what other people did and
not only what other people did. I like
investigating how other languages solve the problem as
well and just kinda compare and how that
works. Like, I I find that more fun
that well, I enjoy solving the problems when
I do solve them. But I find
the more socially bits around that pretty cool
as well. So Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, today's
you know, when when you mentioned this today,
was like, oh, yeah. Yeah. This is this
is good. You know, I have no problem
with this. And then I looked at today's
and I'm like, oh, we're screwed. Right? So
we'll see. What so I'd like to do
is these problems are typically, like, broken down
into two parts. Right? You usually have, like,
you know, an initial problem, and then once
you solve that, you get sort of an
expansion of that problem with the same dataset.
And it's usually kind of like
some sort of
refinement or or maybe even, like, a complete
change of the original original problem. But
and so what
I'd like to do is after looking at
this one, frankly, I have no idea how
to, like like, solve it.
And so,
personally, I just like to get through the
first half, and let's see how quickly we
could do that and efficiently we could do
that. And if we could get through the
first half, then maybe we could tech kinda
tackle the second half. Or if we can't,
maybe we could, like, save that for, like,
the part two or something like that. Oh,
yeah. Definitely. Always up for a part two.
I I've I pulled up the challenge this
morning as well, and I was like, we
we picked the worst day.
Right. Yeah.
Yeah.
Why you doing in fact,
do you have the advent of code screen
up, or shall I pull up a couple?
I can pull Sorry. I'll I'll I'll do
it.
Let's see. Alright. So I'll share my screen
first.
And forgive me if it looks like I'm
staring out out of space. I have two
monitors, and so I have you on, like
Yeah. I I did that too. And I
I I I think I've got it tweaked
just enough that when I look at each
one, it's actually not too bad. Although that's
why it's screen goes right into here and
I probably don't wanna look at that. But
it also means I can't share the screen,
which is also really annoying. Anyway,
not important. So this is advent of code
here. If you're not familiar with it, every
December,
someone goes out of their way. I can't
remember their name. Let me find.
Eric
Wastel Wastel. I'm not sure.
Puts a lot of effort into producing all
of these problems
and they publish one a day, two parts.
You can go and have a bit of
fun with it, share your solutions with other
people. It's just a good way to experiment.
I use it as a way of playing
with new languages generally. I think that's quite
a fun approach to it.
And it's good. And I like what it
what he says here is that, you know,
you don't need to have a computer science
history to be able to tackle these problems
as well. Like, they're they're not there to
stump you or challenge you too much. So
they're to kind of let you to explore
and have a bit of fun with it
as well, which I think is really cool.
Do you have a computer science back? And
you do. Right? Yeah. I I went to
school for computer science. I have, you know,
full full disclosure. I never completed my degree,
but I got really close. But
I sort of and once you start working,
it's hard to, you know, like, go to
school and work at the same time. So
I moved to Orlando with the intention of
finishing my degree, but I'm still working on
that, I guess.
And well, yeah, I I never even started
college or university for computer programming. Like, I
just
I I don't know. I I spent so
much of my youth kind of hacking and
coding and c and I just got my
first role. And I never really felt that
it was holding me back until maybe five
or six years ago when I started to
look at these problems and realized, oh, I
don't know graph theory. Oh, I don't know
how to infer a binary tree and all
these other things. And it wasn't until like,
only in the last five years I started
experimenting with that stuff in my spare time.
So
and I guess the moral of that is
you can actually get a career in computer
science without any of this stuff or at
least a program without any of this stuff.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
I mean, I also like to spend my
time just building CMSs and websites, but that
was fun too.
So today's problem
is a good one. I'm not gonna sit
and and read this all out. Maybe I
can try and summarize it the best as
I can. So the problem is is that
we're gonna be given a dataset, an input
set,
which is a collection of bags.
And there are rules that dictate which bags
can fit instead of which bags. And our
goal is to establish
how many potential combination or what bags we
can get our golden bag into. Is that
a do wanna go into that in any
more detail? Or
Well,
so I think our goal is to count
how many bags in your dataset
can we fit our our golden was about
to scroll your screen. Let me pull it
up too. Oh, yeah. Yeah. We could swap
over. There's no there's no point in me.
Gonna send it back.
So if it's okay, I'd like to share
my screen. Go for it. Yeah. I'll
pop mine off.
Okay. Can you see that okay?
Oh, perfect. Alright. So
let's see.
So, yes, we have, like, a series of
rules that dictate,
like,
what bags can fit in another. Like, in
a light red bag, we could it can
contain one
bright white bag or two muted yellow bags,
etcetera. Some can contain other bags.
So for this problem,
how many bag colors can eventually contain at
least one shiny gold bag?
There's a couple other constraints there
that I think kinda stand out. Let's go
well, there's several there's lots lot of stuff
that stands out. But let's talk about the
fact that
let's see. Where is it? Ah, yeah.
You have a shiny gold bag. If you
wanted to carry it in at least one
other bag, how many different bag colors can
you
I guess my point is I can't find
the the section right now, but
there is a notion of depth like
oh god. Where is it? These
are all specified required contents.
Shiny gold bag if you wanted to carry
it.
Well, let's let's let's get that part for
now. Here's some other things that stand out
is that
the first problem only asks us to count
how many bags we could ultimately fit our
shiny
gold bag into.
But our constraints
have numbers in them. And for the first
solution, I don't I don't see how we're
gonna use that number. But I what I
find is typical with these admin of code
things is that
that's probably gonna be in or, you know,
that number is probably gonna be involved in
the next half of this
half of this problem. There's a a term
I kinda learned I learned a while ago
called Chekhov's gun. It's like a old, like
like, theater concept that if you put a
a gun as a prop or hang a
gun on a as a prop on a
wall, you better use it in the next
in the next scene. And so I think
that that's the thing here. Like, we we
have Chekhov's gun right here in that. We
have one bright white
bag, two muted yellow. So keep that in
mind. So what we'll what we'll try to
do, I guess, is keep track of that
as we as we solve this. Does that
make sense? Or Yeah. Otherwise, I can have
a slightly different understanding from you, which has
got me worried now. So Okay.
Like, the way I read this is that
the light red bag can contain one bright
white bag and two
muted yellow bags. Uh-huh. And then the number
there is for the depth that I think
you're talking about. So if they can hold
two muted yellow bags and a muted yellow
bag can hold two plum bags, then we
need to know that that's four plum bags
that can be held in two muted bags
and say the one
light red bag. Oh, so one more time.
So what what do you mean again? So
let's go over the example and see if
it makes a bit more sense then because
my
understanding is if we have a yeah. Where
is it?
Yeah. So in this example, like, so if
I have a bright white bag that can
hold that can hold away.
Oh, yeah. That's not the rules. Let's see
if I got it here.
Oh, yeah. The buffer oh, that was the
rules. Okay. Yeah. So if we have a
light red bag, then that can hold one
bright white and two muted yellow. Plus we
know from the fourth line that the muted
yellow bag can actually hold two shiny gold
bags plus nine faded blue bags. Mhmm. So
that means we could if then if there's
any combination of nine faded blue bags that
can hold other bags, does that is this
not recursive in that approach or if I
just misread that completely?
I think it is recursive, but I don't
quite understand what you mean by
or how we use that that that quantity
or that volume right there. Okay. So let's
see if I have an example. So if
we've got a muted yellow bag, right, we
know that can hold two shiny gold bags
and nine faded blue bags. Now the two
is important because we know we can hold
two gold bags there. But at the same
time, the nine is important on the faded
blue because we know that faded oh, no.
That was the worst example because faded blue
bags contain no other bags.
Oh, I see what you're saying. So what
you're saying is that if we're gonna sum
up how many shiny gold bags we can
contain let's say, for example, that faded blue
bags could contain shiny gold bags, then you're
saying our total would mean that we could
contain
11 bags. 20 gotcha. Gotcha. So let's see.
So
you have a shiny a shiny gold bag.
If you wanted to carry it in at
least one other bag,
how many different bag colors
would be valid for outermost bag? So what
I get from that is that we have
one bag.
So
regardless if we if, you know, like, say,
a sub sub bag can store nine of
them, it doesn't matter because what we wanna
find out is
so imagine imagine a graph. Right? And so
we
have lot lots of bags or we have
bags that are connected to other bags that
could that could potentially be connected to other
bags. And so I think what we wanna
do is find out
we wanna
and so each of these lines but it
basically indicates kind of a root
or kind of starting point, you know, of
our search. Right? So what I'm imagining is
kind of
searching through this this space.
We're looking for
we're looking to count how many
shiny gold bags we could or
I'm sorry. We're looking for how many distinct
bags
that we could store shiny gold bags in
ultimately. Right? Oh, that's great. And so I'm
saying I think we it already say
light red bag and then traversing graph described
by the these
these sort of adjacent nodes that that these
parts describe.
Right? It's like so light red bag contains,
and then this part, in my mind, describes
the the edges of of the graph. Right?
And so we walk the edges until
and count
the the edges that end
in a shiny
what were a shiny gold bag
node
regardless of the the count. But you might
be right. Like, I what I'm afraid of
is the next part. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Whatever
that is, I think those numbers are gonna
become important. But for this, I don't think
the numbers matter.
Okay. Yeah. I misread it. So, yeah, we
only have to identify the colors that can
eventually hold a shiny gold bag, return that
number, and I bet you part two is
how many gold shiny gold bags can be
stored in this combination.
Right.
Right. Right.
So,
typically, what I like to do is
maybe sometimes to the annoyance of people I
I work with is come up with, like,
really strong metaphors for what we're doing. I
like to I break this down into kinda
like nouns and verbs. Like, what what what
do we have? What what kind of things
we're doing with it?
But, also, in solving these,
just know that we might go down we
might go down paths that
don't work. What what we'll try to do
is break it down into small enough chunks
that if we get to a point where
we're of paying ourselves in the corner, maybe
we could pop pop a few things off
and then kinda kinda restart. Hopefully, we'll see.
But so what I'd like to do is
start with
well, we're gonna do this and go. And
I'm gonna move this to the side of
the screen. So if you see me kind
of, like, stare off in space, I'm looking
at the
the instructions.
Okay.
Let me
k. So I'm gonna open up the terminal.
So we also got our first comment from
John. Hey, John. How's going?
Yes. Sadly, Santa Claus does not create the
advent of code. I'm sorry. Burst that bubble,
mate. Yeah. Yeah. Also, please, if you're in
the chat, please don't, like, spoil it. I
we honestly haven't, like, figured this out. So
I'm I'm open to help, but don't don't
give away the answer. That would be like,
that completely ruined ruined everything for me.
So let's do this.
Use zoom in on the front of it.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Alright.
So we're gonna do this in Go, which
is I already oh, I'm sorry. Let's let's
talk about this program. I mean, this problem
is some more
because this is another thing I see, which
is that
we have the task of traversing this graph,
which is one problem in itself.
Then we have the task of parsing
this stuff.
And
let's take a look at the puzzle input.
And so
hey. This is super long. Right? This is
pretty pretty lengthy.
And
the language
is a little bit complicated. Right? So we
have these kinda like
adjective
noun bags
contains.
So what what I'm seeing is, like, a
little language emerge. Right? So we have you
should have these these two things, an adjective
and noun,
bags contains,
then some number,
and then another adjective and noun,
bags
or bag. That's
so that's, you know, complicated. Right?
Depending on the quantity.
But then the edges of the graph, which
I think we described here,
is actually a comma delimited thing or could
be. Right? Or even worse, it could be
like
where was it?
This one there was one that was, like,
no other bags or something like The rules
are just above you there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So it contains no other bags. So
what I'd like to do is separate this
into two completely prop two completely distinct problems.
One is the act of, like,
following the rules and and traversing the graph,
and then the second part would be parsing
this.
And so let's
let's see how that works for us.
Alright. So
alright. So
what I'm feeling is
so we're gonna write this in Go.
Let's create Go modules. So Go mod with
GitHub.comag64a0cseven.
Okay.
Alright. So I have a go mod file,
so now we could kinda start
kinda hacking away and stuff.
So what I feel when I look at
this is that
what we're modeling is rules.
And so
I consider this kind of an entire rule
set.
Maybe each one of these is a rule.
And so, like, literally, when we're talking about
it. Right? Like, some process would be iterating
over this.
And for each rule
in our rule set,
try to walk
walk the graph until we find some target.
So
what we wanna do is sort of build
a graph,
iterate over each of the nodes or in
in the graph,
and using that as a route, see if
we could
trace a path to a desired target,
I think.
So how do we how do we model
that?
Let's see.
Alright.
Here we go.
So
let me start with Google.com.
Do you write tests when you do this
stuff? Yes. So this is so
in fact,
that is really the only I like none
of my event of code
attempts have, like, a main function. So what
we'll do at some point is split
and then start start running running a test.
So let's start laying down some code first.
So I think the first thing we need
is
a rule,
and
looks like a rule
is gonna need a
name
and a maybe a quantity. Right?
Alright. So quantity is an int. Name is
string. Alright.
Alright.
And
so what we're modeling is
sort of rule sets. Right? So
at some point, we're gonna need a slice
of rules.
So that would be something that encodes
this part right here. Right? So we're gonna
need, like, one bright white,
two muted yellow. Right? And so that feels
like a a slice.
So maybe you could say, like,
type rules.
There's a slice of rule.
And let's start right there. And so here,
let's
start a test. Right? So package,
o c seven.
And let's
okay.
So one of the things I wanna do
is search for a target within
some rules. Does that sound like a reasonable
place to start? Yeah. Yeah. For sure. Alright.
So
rules. I'm gonna say r rules,
and we're gonna contrive some test data here.
But maybe we'll pull some directly from
this input. So I'm gonna copy it from
the admin code page
and paste it here.
K.
I'm gonna drop my font size a little
bit. Is that still okay? Yeah. It's alright.
Yeah.
I'll
tell you what.
So
let's see. So the first rule, have light
red bags.
Alright. So here's something else I'm feeling.
We're gonna need
I feel like we're gonna need
a
rule set,
and we're gonna make that a map of
strings
to rules.
And I feel like that I could use
to kinda stuff all the statements. Right? So
let's say articles rule set.
And
the first rule would be for light red.
In fact, what I'll do is just copy
off this.
Alright.
So what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna try to translate all of this
code for now.
So let's say,
light,
red,
and the rules for that are
one and
bright
white.
And the rules for the second thing is
to when needed.
So you're building out this rule set so
that you can see have an assertion of
when I parse a string. This is a
rule set I get back. Is that So
what I'm doing is so, again, I'm not
I'm not worried about actually parsing this input
right now. What I wanna do is build
my data structure based on this. And so
we're gonna we're gonna kind of, like, parse
it in our heads to start with and
make sure that we're traversing our our tree
our our graph correctly.
And then the second part of that will
be, I feel like, parsing
this this text. And so I feel like
that's a completely separate
thing, and I feel like if we try
to tackle both at the same time, it'll
get confusing and and end of this call.
So,
actually, let's just put this way.
Yeah. There we go.
Alright. So,
in fact,
I'll just do this.
Make that.
Place it here.
And let's see if we can kind of
I don't know if we could do this
programmatically,
but we could certainly do this.
Alright.
I guess we could
maybe
from this slide, that's line 21 to here,
replace
bags with
colon
to get a map syntax.
Alright. So,
also, let's do something similar and get rid
of the word contain.
And let's get rid of the words bags
over the same range.
A bag with potentially an s.
There
we go. Alright. So now we can kinda
It's done.
Thank you. Let's
see.
I feel like I'm trying to see. So,
I mean, that curly braces are off here.
Oh, yeah. They definitely are.
Sorry. This is a boring part of
So what I'm doing now is, again, we're
basically kinda hand hand parsing
that input so that we have some
some data we can use to ensure that
our our algorithm is is is right.
K.
Oh, man.
I imagine Versus Code probably has, like, something
that would make this slide easier to do.
Yeah. Multi link cursors would made it a
little bit easier, but still it's
still fetching.
Yeah. I I think I think I'd probably
do that with the I'm but now we're
we're bumped into our like, the limits of
my VIM
skills here. Alright. So both of these, they
have no address, so we could just say,
like, empty. I guess, these both empty slices.
Alright. Let's see if that that works.
Nope. Something's wrong there. You've not got quotes
around your bright white music yellow, etcetera. Why
didn't you tell me earlier?
Okay. Yeah. I don't want to tell you
at the time either, but your rejects replacing
bag or bags was missing an optional param.
So you've got a couple of bag in
there too.
Right. Okay. Alright. We'll get rid of that.
We'll try to at least see the back
to you at this point.
If if you're watching the recording, fast forward
through this part.
I do appreciate the relative line numbers, though.
I I I don't think I could quote
without them anymore either.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. Here we go. And we'll get rid
of that. Although, one of the things I
worry about is
having the keyword bag
within a color. I haven't looked, but,
it's been my experience that
these, admin code problems,
haven't, like, tried to throw you off by
putting in, like, data. That is that was
weird. It usually it left you to sort
of deal with the the task task at
hand. So
alright. So I feel like we we have
our rule set encoded.
So now is
a matter of traversing it.
So what I feel like I wanna do
is
maybe
let's
do something like
our rule set
find maybe,
and we have a string that we're looking
for.
And
oh, so what we're doing is accounting. Right?
So we don't account.
So we wanna try
okay.
Alright. So
the impression I get is for every node,
we wanna see if our target
is reachable from a particular node.
So I'm gonna iterate over each node then.
So for
let's say,
n is range over r.
Let's return zero for that. And
so now for each node,
what I wanna do is see if I
if I could find a node rooted
at that node.
And I feel like at this point, I
need another another function.
And this is a part that feels recursive.
So given given a node, what I wanna
do is walk
each edge
and see if I could ultimately
recursively land at my target.
And so I think here is where something
I find
is important. So what all I wanna know
is whether or not
this target is findable,
root
rooted from a particular from a particular node.
So I guess also what I need is
so
the first thing I'll do
is
well, before we do any of this,
let's just see what this does.
Alright.
So this let's just run
our our test because I don't wanna get
too far before I realize I have some,
like, major, like,
error or anything like that hiding in there.
So let's just do, like, a t dot
log f
of r
find.
So the node we wanna find is our
both the shiny gold.
Yeah. Shiny gold.
And let's see if we can find it
where we do that.
Right.
Okay.
Alright. So for now, we're just gonna say
go test run
all tests or the reverse way. And, of
course, now I have to you know, the
the program's completely going up.
Alright. So
can I use one type int, type string,
and field value?
Do you not have to import log as
well in your your code or just pump
to print it?
So when I save oh, that that's one
problem. I I I save. I'm running
GoBIM,
and that runs Go imports and GoFund and
all that stuff. And so Oh, nice. Yeah.
Alright. So I think that was oh, no.
It wasn't. So rule test by 21. Can
I use one untyped in as type string?
So I think I just have, like, the
the types
in my thing over yeah. Yeah. So I
have name first and quantity second. So this
should be quantity first name second.
Yeah. Of course. That's great. Alright. So no
major no major problems to to overcome at
this point. Alright.
So
how do you say we how do you
think we should handle
this part? Right? So we have our we
have our graph properly encoded. We have our
rule set
properly encoded. So how do we interpret
in a way that we we find
find our kind of, like, target note?
So
I think
and I'm just dripping here.
What I'd like to do is I think
so okay. So find should be a recursive
function.
I think one of the times that we
bail out is
if, for example,
let's say our rules
and whether or it exists
is
basically,
let's look to see if our current route
is even in our in our
map.
So you could say if rules exist,
route.
And so if not exist
so that is to say,
if we're looking for, for example
oh, here. Shiny gold,
yeah, rooted at light red. If light red
didn't exist, we wanna bail out right away.
Yep. I I think. Right? So that exists.
Return false.
K.
Alright.
Okay. So now the next thing is to
see if
to see if
our rule exists
within
the the nodes that we share.
So
how would we how would we do that?
So okay. I think a good way to
do that what I wanna ask is
if
rules
contains
s.
Right? So what I wanna see is if
my target, you know, s
is
within
the sub slide within the slice
that that that
we've that we've now looked up.
Then we just return true. Right?
Well
And if it doesn't, then we would
we would then search on
the
the notes that it does have recursively.
Well right. So if it if it doesn't,
then what we probably wanna do is search
on the note. So, you know so yeah.
Well, if it
I think what we wanna do is
iterate over this list.
If it's in there,
then we return true. If it isn't in
there, then we run find
on each
one that that
that that that in in in which it
doesn't exist. In fact, at this point, don't
know, but we may wanna run it on
everyone
regardless because there may be
anyway, let's let's let's let's get there. Let's
get there. So alright. So what I'm what
I'm asking now is if the rules contain
my target,
but
I don't have Do have do we have
to implement the contains logic? Because would that
work on our structure? Correct.
So we what I'm gonna do is actually
implement that now. So in the lower right
hand quadrant,
we're gonna say, you know, funk
r rules
contains
s string, and then we'll try to boop.
And what we'll do is we'll iterate over
r. So
let's say the r
oops.
Range of r. And so if
v equals s,
then return true.
Otherwise,
return false.
Okay. So let's see what that looks like
so far.
So if rules contains
that,
then we return
true.
And so for each of these so for
each item in our rule set,
we could say count equals zero.
And then they if
r
find
x
rooted at
n.
So
if I could find this node rooted at
n,
open that account. Oops.
We'll see everything in there.
In fact, what I think the way I'd
like to structure this is if I can't
find it, then continue.
And that's that's just like a kind of
personal thing. I like to think of these
like, I like to think of this as
sort of throwing out state until
I would've went down to the state I
want here.
And at that point,
I I increment increment count. Right?
And
then we return count.
Okay. So in our test, let's see what
that looks like.
So
now we're gonna
count
shiny gold.
And what that'll do is
just print what we're doing here. So we'll
log print f.
Searching for
for value
in
our
our rule set in our in our rules.
Oops.
Sorry. I'm having notifications pop up. I don't
know if you see on the screen, but
please please ignore it. So
here, what I'll do is I'll print n
and r.
Alright. It's gonna run my test.
Oops. I actually kinda use n type rules
as type string and argument.
Oh, I'm sorry. What I mean is s
in
n.
Yeah. I think the next lane is wrong
too.
That n there. Yeah. Because I think what
you pass into find is the
let's take a look at that. Yeah. It's
a string, and we're passing in an integer
right now, I think. Okay.
I'm gonna go outside. Hold on one sec.
Yes, sweetie. I'm gonna go outside. Yeah. That's
cool.
Joys of
at home schooling.
So
where was I? So
we wanna find
our target
rooted at
n.
And so
I'm sorry. So r is a rule set,
which is
this thing.
And so n
Is n a map?
Oh, yeah. So I'm sorry. Excuse me. Excuse
Yeah.
So
our root
and our rules
poof.
Alright. So we iterate iterate over our map.
We're gonna extract the root
or root node that we wanna start our
search
and then the subsequent rules associated
with that.
And in our
nope.
Nope.
I'm sorry. I've kinda lost my place here.
Just give me one sec of I'll do
your tip. Alright.
So
we wanna count. So count
involves finding.
So for each
rule. We wanna
find
so we wanna find yeah. No. This is
it. So, yeah, we wanna find s.
I'll read that and okay. So Okay. Can
I ask a question? Because,
I mean, I've I've got something in my
head that's kinda confusing me, and I'm hoping
you can explain it. So Okay. When we
do the range on r, right, we're getting
two parameters back. One is the key, which
is light red, and then the n is
the rules on this right, which is a
map of tuple. Was that right? Yeah. Yeah.
So this is where I think this is
where I was confusing myself. So what I
want is the
what I want is the name. I want
I want the name of the the node
here. So
I wanna find s
sub n.
I think that's what I want.
But, also, same rules. Right? So
let's let's not do that here. Right. Let's
not do that here. K.
So let's just see what we get.
I'm gonna find it strings. Let's say
up.
Told string.
Roles
line 20.
What am doing here? So
s dot
name.
Yep.
Oops. I'm sorry.
V dot name.
Alright. So
what we've done now is
so for each of these, let's let's let's
print out some, like, output to kinda help
us understand what we're doing what we're doing
here. So
let's say so I'm kind of searching
for
some target, which is
RS
rooted at
some other strength. So our target is s.
The name that we're we're
the name of the root node that we're
gonna start the traversal at is in.
And so what this should what we should
see is that we should have output saying
searching for
shiny gold rooted at light red. Searching for
shiny gold rooted at dark orange, hopefully.
Okay.
Alright.
So now the actual traversal
comes into play. So here's where we actually
do the find.
And let's see then,
like, log for that.
Percent q not found at
percent q. So that's n.
And then otherwise,
percent q
was found.
Great. So,
of course, shiny gold was found because I
think
Viberplum
oh, no. Yeah. So Viberplum
Oh, wait.
Searching for shiny gold. We'll do that. Light
red. Shiny gold was found at Light Red.
Why was that? Have we continued our recursion?
No.
Oh, no. No. So I'm just I'm just
I'm returning I'm returning true. So Oh. Default.
Let's do that. Great.
Great. So yes. Great. So not found
not found not found. But shiny gold was
found rooted at muted muted yellow. Right? And
so why was that? Because
muted yellow actually contains shiny gold. Okay. I
feel like we're getting somewhere. Are we good
so far? We are. Okay. Alright. Okay. Alright.
So what should we do
if
these rules don't contain
contain my value. I think what we should
do is iterate over
my subsequent rules. So for
a rule of is range over
rules. In fact, I just say rule.
And so now
each one of these nodes becomes the root
at which we wanna begin our search. Right?
So if we
can't find it so let's say we start
with LightRed,
and we can't find it
within LightRed. Right? So bright white isn't part
of its rule set nor is it I
mean I'm sorry. So, LightRed doesn't contain it
as part of its as part of its
rule set. So what I wanna do is
see if BrightWrite
has it as part of its rule set,
which is here. So it means now I
wanna call find
rooted at BrightWrite,
but for the same same target. Are we
is that reasonable?
Yeah. That makes sense. K.
So
I think what we wanna say is if
our find
oops.
Our target, which is s,
rooted at
a rule
name.
If we found it, return true.
Otherwise, just keep iterating.
And I think
That's your part.
Okay. So what we have look at that.
Alright. So what we have here is
we search for tiny gold, we did a
bright white. I'm sorry. Shiny gold, we did
a bright white. Shiny gold
was found at bright white. So presumably,
that that returned true.
So now we're searching for shiny gold rooted
at dotted black.
Shiny shiny gold was not found rooted at
dotted black. So now we're looking for shy
shiny
gold rooted at fiber plum.
It was not found.
So then we're searching for well, let's I
think we need to, like, improve our output
here.
So let's kinda log what we're doing. So
Let's see. How can we do this?
So first thing we do is we check
to see if that that node even exists.
If it doesn't exist, return false.
Then we check to see if our target
is contained in that rule set.
If it is, then good. We return fall
true.
Otherwise,
let's say
the map find
within
and let's just print the map at this
point. I mean, the the the the size.
So s
rules.
So
I think I think that might be more
informative. Okay. So let's scroll back a little
bit. Alright. So searching for shiny gold, we're
doing dark orange. Cannot find any shiny gold
within
bright white, muted yellow.
So now
we'll oh, I see.
I feel like we're missing something here. So
we could not find shiny gold within
this slice.
What I think we did next is we
searched for shiny gold within either bright white
or muted yellow,
but I don't see those
I don't see that being put in.
But we can confirm,
I think,
that muted yellow
does contain shiny gold. Oh, I see. We're
just not I see. We're not we're not
printing anything
before we actually do that search.
So
yeah. Here we go.
Searching for
queue within
RV.
So
key
rules.
Yeah. I think that'll give us more data.
Alright. So searching for shiny gold, rooted at
bright white. So that's at a rule set
level. Now for a particular rule, we're saying
searching for shiny gold within
quantity one shiny gold. Of course, it found
shiny gold. It's gonna find itself. We're gonna
have to fix that. Alright. Now we're also
searching for shiny gold.
Oh,
search for shiny gold. We're doing a bright
white.
Yeah. I think that's fine.
Okay. I I'm feeling a little bit of,
like, live coding anxiety, so I'm I'm drawing
a little bit of a blank.
But, yeah, I think I think that
I think what we have
probably does the traversal.
What was supposed to be the the actual
answer? Let's see.
So
Four, which is right.
Okay. Alright.
Alright. So cool. So
let's
I feel good about this, but I don't
feel like I've really, like, demonstrated that it
works. And I guess this is how this
is how a lot of this kinda coding
kinda kinda coding goes.
We got lucky.
We didn't run into any major problems. And
I think, conceptually,
like, we've we've sort of, like, laid out
the task that we want wanted to do
when we and we've executed it.
I think one of the things I could've
done better is maybe printed more debug output
in the right location. But
so let's let's get rid of debug output.
So in the meantime, is there any any
way you think we could sort of
like, any test cases that we could use
to to
kind of expand on this. Oh, well, oh,
I think one of the things we probably
should be doing
is we probably shouldn't find ourself. Right? So
if we
or we we probably shouldn't start
rooted at ourself.
So as we're iterating through this, I don't
think I think we should exclude
this note. Right?
So as we're iterating through our nodes,
if
But but we just return true, don't we?
So
Also
so that was so
that was in the portion where a a
node
contains
a rule
that that contains
that that matches. But what I'm talking about
is as we iterate
over our rules set,
each of the roots.
Well, actually, don't know. Should should so I
guess what would could potentially happen is,
let's say shiny gold points to black black
olive. And I think in this case, it
just works out where the where where this
has happened. But, like, shiny gold
points to both black dark olive and
vibrant plum.
And and I don't think either because of
the way this works out,
neither of those point back to shiny gold.
But if it did let's see. So shiny
gold, dark olive,
Where's dark olive?
Dark olive points to faded blue.
Faded blue points nowhere.
Dark olive points to dotted black. Dot of
black points nowhere. Alright. So where else can
shiny gold go to? You can go to
vibrant plum.
So vibrant plum goes to faded blue, which
goes nowhere as well as
the so what I'm saying is if, for
example, faded blue
instead can contain five
shiny
gold.
So I think the the assumption I made,
this is this is directed because you couldn't
if a shiny gold can fit a faded
blue, then a faded blue can't fit a
shiny gold. Like, if we're talking about the
actual physical dimensions of the bag. Right.
Right.
So but I don't know. Nothing's preventing the
dataset, the actual dataset from contains. That's true.
Yeah.
And so what I expect will happen is
that this might even this should cause an
infinite loop, and this might even, like, cause
my my machine to crash, and I might
have to rejoin the stream. But I'm interested
in seeing what what's gonna happen. Right?
Oh, no.
It actually didn't
didn't crash. But we did get double the
the number. We got an eight back instead
of four.
Alright. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Alright. So So
as you're cursing on itself and then
finding shiny gold and then returning true.
Right. Right. Right. And so oh, right. And
every node that we okay. Yes. Alright. So
I think the way to mitigate that would
be to say
if
n
not equal or n
equals s
or
I find it, then
I think
oh, seven.
If n equal
so n is a name.
Well, let's just say if n equals
s,
continue.
Oh, I see. There's other nodes that lead
to faded blue. So I think this is
counting it.
But
so my point is I think we should
exclude
the node we're looking for from the roots
that that we're looking for. Maybe. I I
might be wrong about that.
But okay. I think we solved it. I
think that is
I typically, what I found is that when
doing these advent of code problems,
pretty much solving
the example
leads to solving the the rest of the
the problems.
We open that file again?
Sure.
The what what do you wanna look at?
The same function.
Okay.
There you go. Let me let me get
rid of some of this. So can we
just do if s equals root there and
then return instead of looking
at the contains? Is that what you're trying
to do there? I think so. So I
think what you're asking is if s equals
If s equals root, then it just return
true.
Do you wanna say true? No? Or would
it be false?
I don't know. Good question.
I think I'm trying to solve a problem
that apparently
doesn't exist yet.
Maybe I'm thinking too far ahead.
But I was Well, add add the recursion
back to our test. I think that's the
s equal can drill with the fix for
that. Right?
I'm I'm saying
as a okay.
In my head, it makes sense.
We have to make that shiny gold, then
we run our test, and we should still
get four.
No. And
I think that's because well, let's let's let's
do this. How about this?
Let's
print
our
know what, and let's see what it's called.
Oh, no. The find should be returned false.
If s equals root, then it should be
a false because it means that we are
in a nested find, so we would be
counting that twice.
No. It's just and so what we're doing
is there's another path. There's another path to
shiny gold. And so let's do something like
this. Say, yep. It's neat. And what we
could say is log f
percent
s
searching for
some
quoted stream
related
at
some quoted string.
And we'll set up strings repeat
tab.
Yep.
Okay.
And so when we
when we go to find, we'll say
depth
plus one.
And maybe,
like, here, we'll start depth with zero.
Alright.
So searching for shiny gold with light red.
I search for shiny gold with a red
dot bright white.
K?
So it must have been terminated,
you know, so you have found it or
not.
Search for shiny gold rooted dark orange, shiny
gold rooted at bright white. And so what
I expect is that we'll see
searching for
I don't know
you know what? I feel like we've gone
down a tangent here that may may not
be necessary.
Okay. And so what we let's let's revisit
this later because the part that's giving me
anxiety is
parsing
the input.
And so at this point,
I'm gonna ask for, you know, as always,
but I'm I'm interested in your help.
I was wondering, like,
what did you think was the best way
to parse this this data?
So shall we look at the input string
again so we can break it down? Absolutely.
And
so I have a I have a notion,
but this is one of those cases where
this is in my toolbox.
It may be something that is dumb. I
mean and what I found is there's times
when I've pulled this out of my toolbox,
somebody else would go, oh, no. I just
use a request for this or whatever, and
it worked out just fine.
But so
I guess I guess I'll ask you your
for your input. And I I'm also gonna
have to take, like, a two second break,
so I'll be right back. Okay? Yeah. Sure.
No worries.
I guess I'm gonna have to work out
how to process text.
So I'll just I'll talk about how I
think it it should be done, and then
you can all tell me if I'm wrong
before Ian gets back. And then I'll look,
like, really smart, which should be cool.
And to me, it kinda breaks down into
two
two different parts.
There's the color bags contain, which is quite
easy to extract out. I don't see any
challenges there. And then on the right hand
side, what we have is some numeric identifier
followed by name, followed by bag or bags
with a comma there. So we can split
that right away on a comma.
Yeah. So we could we could do this
with, like, a recursive strength, but or we
can even just regex it out. Although, I
was trying to avoid the regex because you
know what to say. You know, if you
use regex, you've never got an extra problem
or whatever that weird thing is.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Did did you miss all that? Because I
I just told everybody watching how to fix
it. Oh, really? Well,
great.
Yeah. So
yeah. I was just talking to the problem
in my head to anyone that was listening.
But when it comes to parsing the stringers,
I see some
I I don't know if the right word
is lexical. But, you know, we can split
right away on
we can do a very basic string split
on bags contained, which is consistent. And that
will give us a the name of the
bag on the left, and then something on
the right that we can then start to
tokenize. Now my next thought after that is
that we can then string split on the
comma to get all the different bags on
the right hand side.
And then we could probably get away with
just rejects and out the number and the
name of the bag
from that. So I I think what we're
doing is we're saying, okay. Let's loop over
each line, split it on bags contain.
Left hand side is the name. The right
hand side is our loop, and then we
loop over the comma splits and then rejects
out the number and the bag color.
Okay.
Alright. Was that what you were thinking?
No.
Which is which is good because if I
told you what I was thinking so what
was wanting to do is tokenize the entire
thing. Right? Like So I I
parser for it.
But I actually like what you said better.
So which which route do you wanna take?
We could
we can
we can go either way and We we
we could write Alexa and tokenizer. I I
I think it's a little bit overkill just
because I can see so much consistency here
that all we really need to do is
the first split on bags contain is consistent.
Right? Really, really easy.
We then get the comma to do the
split on the number of items on the
right. I mean, I'm comfortable with the rejects
at that point because it's trivial to get
the numeric identifier and then anything up to
a space bag.
I mean, that's it really is really simple
reject. But if you've got a nicer way
of handling that, then we can go that
way. I know. Let's
see. Let's see what we could do here.
Oh, let's try that.
Sorry. I'll keep you right. We'll be fine.
Alright.
So
well, let's call the scan that go. Right?
Okay. So
I'll do it with a pause, I guess,
but let's start with a scanner.
Maybe it'll take a
a room scanner.
We'll take a take a reader, IO reader.
The
first thing you'll do is,
let's say, we'll create a line oriented
Yeah. Pop. Io new scanner. Right? So let's
say, like,
standardtools.i0newscanner
r. And by default, that that splits it
on lines. And so
while we scan,
you could say, just for fun for right
now, log for that.
Scan text.
Right?
And let's start test.
Alright. So
yeah. So what we could do is let's
paste our
test input into here as an example data.
And that did not work as planned.
There we go.
And
so we'll say, like, input
equals
and lose the
back ticking go, which
gives us sort of an uninterpreted
string
kinda literal. So no escaping or anything like
that. And so now since we're passing scan
and IO reader, we could say, like, scan
strings,
new reader input.
Alright. So now we can say go test,
run,
test, scan,
and what we should see is
what we should see is each one.
Yep. Okay. So now we wanna split on
bags. Alright?
So I don't know bags contain.
Okay. Alright.
So strings index,
so that gives us the index of bags.
You know? So that gives us the index
of a of a substring.
So for for each of those, we could
say
oops.
So the first parameter would be
scanner text,
and the second one would be
should we split on space bags contain?
Yeah.
Alright. So now we could maybe say log
for now.
Root is
something,
and rest is something else. Right?
And so our route would be well, let's
let's stash our our scanner text because it's
gonna get cumbersome calling scan text all the
time. So let's just say text equals
scan text. Could we just use strings dot
split on the bags container? Like, I don't
know if there's a reason we do the
index or you're just doing that for the
debug output?
So I guess we could do on the
split chain string.
Oh, yeah. Strings dot split?
Oh, yeah. This is string. It gives us
a slice.
Well, I was just gonna reslice it. So
I was just gonna say, like,
text,
you know, up to index
and then test I'm sorry.
Up to index and then
text
via
from index and beyond.
Will it have to be will it have
to be index plus the number of characters
and space bags contained?
Yeah. Yeah. So we're we're kinda capturing capturing
that. So you're right. I think yeah. So
split
is better.
Alright. So we're gonna split on bags contained,
and we're gonna say
maybe
parts.
And let's print
oh, they'll call it part.
Zero and part one.
Let's see what we get.
Good old go.
Yeah. I know. Right? Alright.
There you go. Alright. So the root is,
red. The rest is one bright white bag.
Oh, I love it. That's awesome. Good deal.
Alright. So
And then we can do the same on
a comma to get all of the items
and then
the magic of projects.
Alright. So rules equals strings
split
part
one
on
On
a comma. Comma. Yeah.
Alright. It's supposed to be rules.
Okay.
Just for now.
Alright. So
our rules,
bright white bag. Oh, wait a sec. Something
is not quite right about that
because
That doesn't look like that was split.
Am I doing wrong here?
So rules, red white bags.
I'm good at yellow bags.
Roles
split.
So strings up.
So see where you've got
so
we've got the split and base container, which
gives us part which gives us part zero
and part one. Why
is it there I I don't know what
the real assignment is. Can that just be
removed?
Well, so
in our hypothetical,
like, rules struck the root
is gonna be here, and then we're gonna
have
you know, that's gonna be the root of
our map, and then we're gonna have a
slice of
rules
after that.
So I guess I don't have to stash
the root just yet. I was just trying
to give it kind of a name
beforehand.
Alright. Okay. Can I see the output again?
Oops. And
Okay. So
it was able to extract the root, which
is, like, red. Mhmm.
And then the rest,
I'm sorry, the rules here. So
this looks like a a slice of length
instead
of like, I don't see a comma here.
Maybe I'm just reading the output wrong. Let's
let's print it in a way that go
That's it.
Oh, okay. That's right. I'm sorry. So Yeah.
Yeah. So we we did it.
Alright. Well, we still have to reject each
of the rules now to get the quantity
and the name, but I think that should
be pretty trivial.
Yeah. And in fact, I think we could
avoid using rejects by
using scan f. Right? So I think we
could do something like
let's see. So count zero
word one
is
word one and word two
is the string.
And we might be able to simply say,
font s scan f
rules.
Oh, I'm sorry. Well, first,
for each rule
rules,
I'll just scan f.
So we want an integer.
So one
string string,
and we're gonna pass this the address of
count.
Address of word one and address of word
two.
And we Not sure if that'll work because
the name of the bag oh, I guess
it's two strings. Right? It's always two strings.
We're not we're not gonna get, like, a
pale, like, red in our test data, are
we?
I don't know. So what I'm hoping is
that so what we just did was we
gave so we're getting a string in the
form of, like I'm just gonna copy this
and paste this into the into the
so
we're doing in the string in, like, this
form. Alright? So that's
an integer. So that's covered by a percent
d
a word, percent covered by percent s, another
word covered by percent s. And I'm hoping
that we just completely
ignore
that part in our
s k n f verbs.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
What we also need to handle like, what
happens if that scan f fails for the
new other bags? Can we handle that?
Yes. Exactly. Yeah. So what we could say
is, I think it returns the count. So
n error
equals that. I think. Go to the
front scan
scan.
Yeah. It returns an integer. That's number of
patterns that that it matches and then an
error.
So I imagine the error
it gets when
whatever data it's reading go to whatever
whatever whatever pattern it gets doesn't match the
type of the value that you're writing into.
Okay.
So
what we could just say here is, basically,
if n does equal three
or error does equal nil,
discontinue.
But
let's also just for our own
own
satisfaction,
indicate that we failed to scan this line.
Yeah.
And, hopefully, the only things that pop up
are the, like, no
no.
Which one? Alright.
Think that's it. Looks good.
I feel like my friends are now. So
I don't where where I go wrong.
Alright. So we have
let me see what the range for the
rules.
Alright. So let's see what that does.
Nice.
I think all the fails are in the
other bags.
Yep. Two of them.
I hate to admit it. I'm like I
said, I'm suffering from a little bit of
live coding pressure. I don't even see the
failures right now.
There's just the the bottom six lines are
the two failures because the last two bags
are
Yeah. Great. Perfect. And so barring that failure,
let's print out our
account.
Oh, let's say
our node
name is
word one plus space word two.
And then let's reconstruct our node here. So
found rule.
B is an s.
My dog's under my desk right now trying
to convince me to throw a ball with
her right now. It's my
heart.
And so
count
mode.
Okay.
Great.
Cool. So we prep for found.
Awesome. So we found rule one, bright white.
Rule two, muted yellow.
And so if we look at our input,
light red bags contain
white,
muted yellow.
I'm gonna go with this for now. Are
you okay with it? Uh-huh.
Okay. Alright. So let's construct our graph using
this now. So each one of those are
rules. So we start with
let's start with a
rule set,
and that's gonna be initialized to
rule set
or a new rule set.
And
for each rule we read,
we have a
rule name.
That would be part one.
Let's see what else.
And so for each role name in our
rule set, we could say
we wanna append a rule.
So, actually, let's start the new
rules. So
rules equals
an empty rules size.
And so for each rule, we wanna say
rules equals append
rules,
and the value we wanna pin to that
is a rule
containing
do you remember our our rule value? I'm
gonna split this. I'm sorry. We're kinda
getting into
It was quantity and name, if that's what
you're looking for.
Yeah. Thank you.
Quantity
would be
count. I said it's called account, but I
should probably call it
quantity just to
keep everything
keep all my terminology consistent.
That's the p is quantity.
And
Name is.
Sweet. And then once all of this is
done, we could say
role
set.
Your name
equals
rules.
And at the very end, let's
let's return rule set.
Yeah. Then we're start against that one we
built up earlier. Right?
Yes. Exactly.
And so I'm feeling All coming together. It's
all it's all coming. So
and, again, I apologize for, like, the terminology.
And as you could as you're as you're
aware, all this is kind of evolving.
And in an ideal world, maybe some of
the variable names and other things that we
use might be better than this or more
better or better thought out, but
it is what it is for now.
Alright.
Oops.
Okay.
So I feel like I went wrong. So
It doesn't like that redefinition of rules on
test on 13 because it's defined 21 above.
Sorry. Down a bit.
Underneath the second blue comment, you've got a
redefinition of rules.
Okay. Thank you.
So how should I mitigate that? I think
the first one should be, like, rule list
or rule string or something like that because
it's
they're not really rules yet.
Gotcha.
What's the rule
list?
And then the range and two two down
is rule list.
K.
It's still very unhappy. I need to play
that.
Oh,
role list.
We want that to be rules list. So
rule list
rules
list.
Undefined
quantity,
p u a n t I t y,
p u a n alright. Let me do
it. Learn how to spell.
And count.
Okay.
Great.
So now we're logging. So now now, theoretically,
our
result of scan should
be a proper, like, rule set. And so
we should be able to say, like, t
dot log.
I
thought I just put a ball right, like,
on my lap. No.
And so we should be able to print
this,
and this is what we get. Alright. So
map, one bright bag.
Okay. So this is actually a problem.
Oh, okay. So
the problem is
the index of my rule. That should be
well, I was calling
my
root.
So that's part zero.
What I'm putting in there now, rule name.
Next rule.
It's
part one. So, yeah, what I want here
is
part, oops,
part zero,
which
I think is out of scope.
I know. I said real name is is
defined and unused.
Oh, okay. I just did it on that.
Sorry.
Oh, no. I don't think that was a
problem. Oh, yeah. Okay. Okay. Go for that.
That's fine.
Alright.
Okay. Great.
So we have our map. This is bright
white,
and it points to
So should we should we copy the map
definition from our other test into that one?
It just assert against it. Totally. That's a
great idea.
So
where is that? It's the rules test.
So I should be able to you wanna
call that out,
and we'll paste it
here.
I'm just gonna get rid of this other
clutter.
Okay. So
and so maybe we could stash this in,
like, parsed rule
set.
And now let's just visually compare it because
what I'm afraid of is so what I'm
thinking is we could use, like, reflect deep
equal to see if they're actually the same.
I don't know yet.
But just to get a sense of satisfaction,
what I'd like to is just print into
the screen and see if we could visually
compare that. Are you okay with that? Or
you think I Yeah. Can you do a
search first for d p o t?
One more time?
Do a search for d p o t.
It's just a typo that you were you
must have then command.
Yeah. So that should be dotted.
You were trying to paste in there. Got
it. Thank you.
Alright.
And so just t dot log f
percent
v
r
and then t dot log f
cost
rule set.
Alright. And so
at a glance, they look identical. Quantity
six.
I'm willing that that was a typo somewhere,
maybe, but we'll see. Alright. So we have
a map, bright white,
quantity one, shiny gold,
dark olive, quantity three, faded blue,
24.
I think the ordering is just different.
Alright. Well, so No. Maybe not.
Where did they deviate?
What's that again?
I'm just trying to see where the the
deviate after faded blue into light red.
Interesting.
The end of the the end of the
second line after faded blue. So the faded
blue on the parsed lines doesn't have any
rules,
which I actually think is correct. So did
we modify the test case? Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. We did. We did. Yeah. Yeah.
Sabotaging ourselves. Yeah.
Oops.
Alright. So
that looks right. In fact, they ended at
the right place.
Yeah. In fact, I think we could do
something like
let's see. Photoshop reflects
equal.
Alright.
So give two things. It turns a bull.
Alright. So let's check to see if
reflect deep
equal
r parsed
rule set.
If that equals
false,
then
t dot fatal
Ours data that doesn't match
expected.
Whatever.
This isn't yeah. This isn't productive code. Thank
you.
Alright.
So where are we? So let's run this
test and see if it fails or passes.
Hey. It passed. Cool.
Alright.
So
how far are are we into this? So
an hour and twenty four minutes in. Actually,
maybe a little bit more than that.
If you just add kinda, like, random stuff.
We've successfully parsed the data. We think what
we have successfully
traverses the the the graph.
So now what I'm ready to do is
just try this on the test data that's
included. Alright. Are you good with that, or
do you see anything else that we need
to do? No. I think we smashed it.
Okay. I think so.
But whatever whatever definition to smash,
one of these. Right? Alright. So let's just
copy all the data out. And so something
nice we could do is we could say,
tap this input
dot text
and paste it.
Alright. So now we have this nice input
dot text. And so within GoTest, we can
actually
load local
or load test files, and
and and the test is run
with the current working directory,
the same as, like, your package. And so
I could refer to any, like, test files
just using, you know, sort of, like, the
current current path. So I could do something
like
so
let's go back to our
rule test profile.
I mean, we could we just we could
just create, like, a main dot goal, scan
that file with an IO reader, and then
call
finder. Right? And then open a value.
Yeah. Or we could do it within a
test. Right? So, like, we don't have a
main package here. So we could simply say,
like, funk test.
I don't I can't think of a good
name for this now. I'm feeling a little
bit embarrassed by not naming this well, but
this is kind of like our final test.
Right? So let's just call this a o
c seven
part
one
t testing
dot t.
And so what we could do is we
could say, like, in the file,
error equals OS open,
and what do we name it? We put
that text. I guess we'll find out soon
enough.
If error does equal nil,
then we encountered
some problems. So t dot fail
or t dot fail,
and then out of the error. Otherwise, let's
defer
posing
our our input.
Oops.
And then now we could say
rule set our rules
equals
oh, let's call it rule
set equals
scan
I
don't remember if we chose to return an
error. So I guess, typically, what I'd like
to do is return an error of some
kind, but where,
yeah. And so
we'll set
count,
and
let's look at our
test here. So we wanna count
shiny gold. Right? So
and let's log
the results of that.
Alright. Here we go. So that's it. So
we
kind of modeled our data type,
implemented traversing our our struct
our our our data structure.
We wrote a parser for our input and,
in fact, generated the the our graph.
And so now we're gonna this is where
the kind of rubber meets the road,
and we're gonna run a test for
a o c one
part
one
to build a test
when
that
verbose.
Yeah. There's an error. Too many arguments called
fatal.
Oh, I'm sorry. It's Oh, fatal. Alright. Yeah.
Alright. So it's just getting producing a lot
of nice output,
and it counted a 12.
Is that the right answer? I don't know.
I'm
I'm super worried about this because
I've only I've only entered the wrong answer
once.
And
I was
and and so I felt like I was
kinda, like, on a roll.
And so I don't wanna do it twice.
But if you're good with it, I'm willing
to, like, type this into the into the
interface and see if this works. What do
you think? I alright.
Here we go.
So let's pull this tab over here.
What what do we say again? A 12?
Yeah.
Oh, jeez. Okay.
What do we do if this doesn't work?
Like, do we still go back to drawing
board or do we just say, you know
what? You gave me a good try. Yeah.
I've gone to the pub.
Alright. Here we go.
Ah, yes.
That was it.
We did it.
Good job. Nice. So I'm afraid to go
on part Oh, man. My dog's, like, really
harassing me. This is a good time to,
like, let her out and and take a
break. Is is that okay, or do you
wanna do you wanna say part two for
later? Yeah. Let's say part two for later.
I'm I've gotta have dinner with my wife
and stuff, but
I'll we can we can sort that out
for sure. Okay. Alright.
Did you do you wanna pick up later
on this evening, or did you wanna just
do it another time? Or do you wanna
just skip it and just say, like, hey,
this is how this is how I wanna
answer
part one of this admin of code thing.
See, you never know what part two is.
Sometimes it's, like, something you're gonna do in
fifteen, twenty minutes, and then sometimes it's something
that's, like, crazy bigger. Let's take a quick
look. Let's take a look. Yeah. Okay. Alright.
So
it's getting pretty expensive to fly these days,
not because of the ticket prices, but okay.
Let me let my dog out because she's
what's gonna happen is she's eventually gonna unplug
my computer.
It looks fun.
So consider
getting your shiny gold bag and the rules
from the above example. Contains zero other bags.
Contains
so a single shiny gold bag must contain
one dark aloe of that. It's
plus two
the 11 bags within each of those. So
this is exactly what you predicted. Right? Because
now what we wanna see is,
I think
oh, so, of course, the rules have a
small chance of giving several levels
deeper than this example. Be sure to count
all of the bags even if the nesting
becomes topologically impractical.
So here's another example. Shiny gold bags contains
two dark bags.
Dark red bags contains two
dark orange bags.
So this example, a single shiny gold bag
must contain
a 26
other bags.
Oh, so true. So it's okay.
Not because of ticket prices, but because of
the ridiculous number of bags you need to
fly.
Consider again your shiny gold bag and the
rules from the above example.
K?
So a single shiny gold bag must contain
one dark olive bag
and the seven bags within it plus
two.
And,
of course, these actual roles have smaller chance
at going through.
Yeah. So we have to recursively loop over
counting
all the quantities to get, like, a cumulative
sum of how many bags spent in all
the other bags. I think that's easy. Okay.
Let's let's try this.
Let's see if we can knock this out
in a few seconds. So
let's look at where will that go. So
I think all all we have to do
is
as we recurse,
we can accumulate
a
a sum. So let's say sum.
Let's say sum is a pointer.
Alright. So the base case of this is
if we find a bag that this could
fit in.
Oof.
Hold on. I need to look at this
again.
So for each node, like so what I'm
imagining is that
as we path it's a path from our
root to the actual node that we're looking
for.
I think what we wanna do is
accumulate a sum that is
for
each
sub bag
that contain our
bag that we're searching for.
So
this
oh, let's see. So
so for
a little shiny old bag must contain one
dark olive bag
and the seven bags
within it
plus two vibrant plum bags.
And so if there were
and the 11 bags within each of those.
Yeah. So instead of returning a true like
we do now in the find, what we're
actually gonna have to do is then
call account on each of those trues to
return the number of bags.
So every time we come across a bag,
we're gonna need to, a stack where we
add it to it. And then we're gonna
have to look over the stack during the
count.
K.
So maybe we can return
minutes.
I
don't think we have to return a bill.
We I mean, we could just return a
zero.
K. I'm just afraid of, like, changing everything
else we've done.
I'm okay with that.
Oh, so the I guess that's the thing.
So that's gonna change the signature of everything.
So I think it's a find what we
wanna do is just make another function call
count.
And but we could do the same thing.
So we could say, like
so for everything from
line 10
to here,
can get that.
And make a new function called count,
and it's gonna turn to mute.
Sorry.
I will call it sum.
Alright. So
what happens is I think the base case
is if we actually find
well, it is if we actually or one
of the base cases if we actually find
our target. But, otherwise, we could return zero
where we don't find it.
Here's another case where we would probably return
zero.
If if we if the rules contain
this,
maybe we could have,
like
instead of rules contains, we could say rules
I guess we could just negate that and
return zero?
What we wanna do is find the count
of And so if it doesn't contain it,
we return the cumulative sum. And if it
does, then we wanna look over all of
those bags and then increment the account with
those. Right? Yes.
So
here, if it doesn't contain it
oh, I see what you're saying.
Mhmm.
Yeah. So lane
where you've got f rules dot contains, if
we just negate that and and so we
know that it doesn't contain it, then we
can just return whatever the account has at
that point in time. Is that maybe that's
too too naive. No. No. No. I'm sad
that you've naive. So rules is a slice.
And so
what we're doing in contains is we're iterating
over that slice
and seeing if we find a rule that
matches that name.
But instead, I think what we wanna do
oh, I see what you're saying. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So if we don't find
that, then return zero. Thank you. That's really
good.
Okay. So,
otherwise,
what we wanna say is
equals roles
out.
And
discount
Oh, okay. So here are a couple so
there's a chance that
and I think that's what, this warning is
about. Right? So,
where is it? Alright.
So, of course, the actual rules have a
small chance of going several levels deeper than
deeper than this example. Be sure to count
all of the bags even if the nesting
becomes topologically impractical.
So I think what can happen is we
might have loops, but maybe not. But also,
a bag might contain
or
a bag might contain another bag
that might contain
I
guess I'm getting at is what I'm feeling
at this point is that
I should continue through this loop.
But at the same time, I need to
be able to note
when we found,
how can I say this?
My field is we need to note when
we found an entire chain or an entire,
yeah, an entire path
somehow.
And I'm not sure. I kinda painted myself
in a corner here because
we might find multiple multiple paths,
but how do I how do I
account for that?
Unless
actually, I guess I guess it's
alright. Yeah. So I I don't think that's
a problem. So
our total count for this loop
is
such.
Our count equals our count.
I can even say maybe total
plus equals
that
and return the total.
What do you think?
So now
let's edit our roles
test again,
and let's do part two.
So
eight here. Yank.
Two.
Scan.
Okay. Awesome.
Awesome. Okay.
Hold on a sec. My wife's ringing.
Okay.
Alright. So
I think that works.
I think.
Although this is complaining.
Spectator.
Open. Yeah.
Some takes the string that are written at
that.
Oh, yeah.
K. You're not passing in the rule set.
So it would be
yeah. Something's missing there. Because you're and rule
set does some of your passing shiny gold,
but you're not passing in
the root strength.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, I see. Yeah. Alright. So we'll set
some.
This account.
Alright. So our name we're just kinda stretching
our naming here. But so I guess what
I could say is
some here changes to lowercase
some so that we're not gonna expose.
And then so for each of these, we'll
say
sum
Yeah. Right.
Plus equals sign of
that,
and we'll return the total.
And then so this
Right. Right.
Right. So we're good? Yep.
Still complaining. Rule 87.
Oh, it's still inside.
I aborted that code. Okay. So too many
arguments.
Alright. To count
so I changed
oops. This Yeah. That should be sum.
That should be count, and this one should
be
sum.
Oh, I am so sorry. I'm feeling like
I
help me out here.
Yes. So and your sum function, there's a
call to count, which should be sum with
a capital s.
Yeah. There.
That should be calling some, sorry, with a
small s. Yeah. Okay.
Thank you.
Alright.
Alright. So let's test
AOC seven part two.
Alright.
So we got zero.
Oops.
Yeah. Let's let's make sure that part one
still works.
Alright. Alright. So what do I do in
Rawkode? So
when we sum,
we wanna call lowercase sum.
Alright. So maybe so I'm in reading for
this.
So there there's a problem. We're we're always
looking looking
or searching using the same route.
Oh, no. No. We're not. We're searching for
shiny gold rooted at each one these. Alright.
That's good.
And so we're
calling lowercase sum
with our
target
and our root.
And what we do is we say if
s equals root, return zero.
If we could find the root
or if we can't find the root, return.
If
it doesn't contain
that value, then we return.
But if it does contain it
Actually, I think this is this logic is
backwards. If it does contain it, we'll just
return
yeah. So here, I think, is where we
wanna return
the value
of the node.
Oh, yeah. We're not doing anything with quantity
yet. Right. Right. So that that's where we
wanna return the value of the quantity.
Yeah. So
let's just say, like, q two I
equals
those container s
minus rooms
quantity.
And so here in contains, we'll change this
to
there we go. I'm just gonna just say,
t t y.
If
if the name equals, we'll return
v dot quantity.
Otherwise, we'll return
zero.
I'm assuming that if quantity
is equal or if quantity
equals zero
Quantity will always be a positive integer.
Well, yeah, it'll always be a positive integer.
But if it's zero,
that means
we didn't find it. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Gotcha.
And and I think but if we did
find it, then we wanna return that quantity
right then and there. So quantity is equal
zero,
then return
quantity.
Alright. Now
for each of our rules,
based on the rule, fortunately,
we we we held on a depth because
that could be our our factor that we
multiply.
Oh, maybe not. Maybe not.
So total rule
quantity
times
the sum of
any rules below it. Okay.
Alright. There we go. It's recursing.
It's a lot of stuff. We
have a number. Oh, how do we do
it?
Fifty fifty.
Yeah. So I actually feel pretty good about
this. I don't I don't know the answer,
but I
I'm feeling good about it. I I'm gonna
enter it, and I say if it if
it works,
it works. If not, then that's really high,
though. That's a really high number. It's a
big data center. It's
Let's try it.
Okay. Alright. Here we go. The worst that
happens is it works. We celebrate. If it
doesn't,
when oh, well, we
we'll try again another time.
We're coming up to, like, two hours and
ten minutes now. Think this has been a
Yeah.
Yeah. It's way too high. Alrighty, man. Well,
that was it. That was my terrible attempt.
I told this. I'm sorry. I wish I
I wish No. It was good. That was
really good.
Thanks for your help.
I feel like I let you down.
No. I think that was really good fun.
I think, you know
I mean, considering what we tried to sort
of together there for that quantity thing at
the end, like, I think I'm afraid. I
pray solid effort. What I would suggest is
that if you could push that code to
get help, that would be really cool. And,
you know, if you, you know, if you're
available this week, we should definitely pick up
another one of these and have. Because I
I really enjoyed just seeing how you think
and how you kinda handle this. To me,
it was really cool. I really enjoyed that
one. That's good. Oh, cool. Cool. Alright. Well,
thanks thanks for the opportunity. I really appreciate
it.
I guess,
yeah, in closing, it was awesome working with
you at at influx.
I already missed my team.
I look forward to the to the next
gig. And I hope that
the people at my next my next employer
hadn't seen this and they couldn't judge me
judge me by this, and I feel like
reconsidering at this point. So
but but
yeah. That's it. Thanks for the opportunity. Had
a really good time. No. It was my
pleasure, honestly. Thank you for that. I'll speak
to you afterwards.
We'll try and get something else sorted out,
and it was good. So thank you very
much. You have a great day, man. Alright?
Cool, man. Bye bye.